successful people just don't sleep like
that's kind of a prerequisite to being
successful so true you're not getting
your standard nine hours and that's why
I feel like I'm definitely Limited in My
Success like I think I'm probably close
to like hitting my Peak because like you
bet your ass I'm sleeping nine hours a
night yeah I slept nine hours outside I
woke up like I was hit by a truck like
it wasn't enough time no I slept not
enough hours last night I woke up at 4
30. maybe that means you're like in your
successful era totally except it's not
like I like did something productive
towards my career this morning you
reared your child but I did wear my
child that's productive towards
everything that's true towards having it
all